WELCOME BACK.
DAVID IS STILL WITH US AND
WERE JOINING BY DOCTOR ANDREW
BOGAN.
I’M YOU HANDED OVER TO YOU,
WHERE WOULD YOU LIKE TO PICK
THAT UP AND WHAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ADD TO WHAT’S ARE
READY BEEN DISCUSSED?
>> I THINK YOU’VE CAPTURED
VERY WELL THE IMPORTANCE OF
DOING PREVALENCE TESTING AND
REALLY UNDERSTANDING WHERE WE
ARE.
I THINK THAT’S NOT KNOWN, I
THINK STUDIES LIKE OURS WHICH
CAN BE REPLICATED VERY QUICKLY
AROUND THE WORLD SHOULD BE
DONE AND WILL HELP INFORM WHAT
THE REAL NUMBERS LOOK LIKE.
>> SO I JUST WANTED TO ASK YOU
TO COMMENT ON, THIS IS A
CRITICAL TIME, DECISIONS ARE
BEING MADE ABOUT WHAT COMES
AFTER THE APRIL 30 NATIONAL
GUIDELINES, THERE’S QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW DO WE REOPEN OUR
ECONOMIES.
I JUST LIKE YOUR TAKE ON THE
TWO PLANS, LET’S JUST START
WITH THIS PLAN WHICH THERE
SEEMS TO BE A LOT OF PEOPLE
SAYING LET’S TEST EVERYONE,
VIRUS TEST EVERYONE, AND THEN
WE CAN ISOLATE THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THE VIRUS AND TRADE THEIR
CONTACTS AND SO ON AND MANAGE
THIS GOING FORWARD.
DOCTOR FACTORY SEEMS TO BE
VERY KEEN ON THAT APPROACH.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT?
>> SO TESTING IS IMPORTANT,
BUT WE HAVE TO REALIZE THAT
THERE MAY BE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE ALREADY HAD THIS
DISEASE AND YOU WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO TEST FOR ACTIVE VIRUS
IF TRADITIONAL TESTINGS BEEN
DONE.
YOUR ONLY BE ABLE TO TEST IF
THEY’VE HAD THE VIRUS LIKE THE
ONE WE DID OR THE LABORATORY
VERSION USED BASE DANFORD
RIGHT NOW.
BUT I DON’T THINK IT’S GOING
TO BE PRACTICAL IF THE NUMBERS
OF INFECTION ARE AS LARGE AS
THEY MIGHT BE AS YOU SUGGESTED
EARLIER TO BE DOING THIS
TESTING TESTING.
I THINK THERE’S A VERY REAL
CHANCE THAT THIS DISEASE HAS
PROGRESSED MUCH FURTHER THAN
WE REALIZE BASED ON THE BIAS
OF HOW WE BEEN DOING TESTING
SO FAR, AND IF WERE ABLE TO
DISCOVER THAT WAS THE CASE,
I’M VERY HESITANT TO SAY THAT
IT WOULD BE FEASIBLE TO
CONTRACT TRACE EVERY SINGLE
INFECTIOUS CONTACT.
>> THAT’S AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT POINT.
YOU MADE IT REALLY CLEARLY.
WE HAVE TO UNDERLINE THAT
BECAUSE THIS SEEMS TO BE THE
DIRECTION OUR POLICYMAKERS ARE
GOING IN.
THE OTHER ONE DAVID, IT’S THIS
IDEA OF ANTI- BODY IMMUNITIES
CERTIFICATES TO SAY WELL IF
YOU HAVE IT YOU CAN GO BACK TO
WORK, BUT IF THE OTHER PERSON
IN YOUR HOUSEHOLD HASN’T HAD
THE VIRUS THEY STILL HAVE TO
STAND THE SHUTDOWN.
WHAT YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> LIKE YOU MENTIONED, YOU
COULDN’T OF SAID IT BETTER
STEVE IN YOUR OPENING
MONOLOGUE, YOU CAN’T LET
PEOPLE GO BACK TO WORK IF THEY
DON’T HAVE IT BECAUSE IT
CREATES THIS PERVERSE
INCENTIVE THAT YOU’RE GONNA GO
OUT AND TRYING GET SICK
ESPECIALLY IF YOU’RE NOT GOING
TO GET THAT SICK, BUT IT COULD
CREATE A MUCH BIGGER CRISIS.
JUST TO ADD SOMETHING THAT
ANDREW JUST SAID ABOUT THE
MASS TESTING, IF 50% OF THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE IT DIDN’T EVEN
KNOW THEY HAVE IT, AND 85% OF
PEOPLE HAD A MILD CASE AND
NEVER GOT TESTED, HOW CAN YOU
TRACE 50% OF THE PEOPLE WHO
HAD IT AND DIDN’T KNOW THEY
HAD IT.
THAT’S JUST CRAZY.
YOU CAN SEE WHY THESE NUMBERS
THAT ARE COMING OUT, THERE’S A
STUDY OUT OF DENMARK THAT
SHOWS 30 - 80 TIMES AS MANY
PEOPLE HAD THE ANTIBODY,
THERE’S A STUDY OUT OF GERMANY
THAT SAYS 15% OF THIS TOWN
ALREADY HAS IT WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT’S LIKE A
HUNDRED TIMES WHAT THE GERMAN
TEST RATE IS TODAY SO LIKE
ANDREW SAID, THIS IS PROBABLY
GONE WAY BEYOND THAT WE SHOULD